Here's the start of our program. I've setup a few variables. Note the initial
balance of $100. My target of a million dollars. The interest rate of 1%, and
right now we're in year zero. In Java, you use the while loop to repeat
statement. And that's exactly what we need. We want to repeat the statements
that add the interest. Here, we compute the interest. Here we add the interest
to the balance. Each time we do that, we also want to increment the year
because after all, we want to keep track of how many years this process takes.
And finally, we want to print out. Just so that we have a running total of the
current year and the current balance which is what you see here. How long do we
want to do this? We want to do it while the balance is less than the target,
the balance starts out at a $100 gets larger and larger. Eventually, it'll
exceed the target and then the loop will stop. Now, let's run this program and
here it runs. Look at this, after 926 years, we've reached a million dollars.
That's actually not so bad. So, I have to wait less than a millenium to become
a millionaire. You can do the same thing.